[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
حادثه لاطلاق النار في وسط العاصمه
الفرنسيه
وقوات روسيه تواصل التدريبها في بيلاروسيا
الارصاد السعوديات تصدر تحذيرا متقدما من
هطول امطار غزيره على مناطق من غرب البلد
في الرابعه ايضا
سالك السعوديه التابعه لصندوق الاستثمارات
تستحوذ على نسبه من شركه سنغافوريه بنحو 5
مليارات
مهرجان فيست للاكل السعودي في نسخته
الثانيه
من مختلف المناطق
اعلنت السلطات الفرنسيه مقتل واصابه
باطلاق نار بشارعين في منطقه الدائره
العاشره في العاصمه باريس اشاره سائل
اعلام الفرنسيه الى ان الحادثه وقع امام
مركز استقبال اللاجئين اكراد في العاصمه
وقال للدعاء العام انه يبحث في دوافع
عنصريه على خلفيه الحادث واكد وزير
الداخليه الفرنسيه جراند
اعتقالا المشتبه به بتنفيذ الهجوم الذي
قال مكتب للدعاء العام انه يبلغ 69 عاما
وقد سبق للمشتبع به وتورط في محاولتي
واشارت الى انه او وسائله على اشاره لانه
هاجم قبل مركز
باريس ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حسين
القنيبر حسين مرحبا بك ضعنا اولا في اخر
التطورات والمعلومات حول هذه الحادث
اهلا بك يا خالد ابدا بالجديد الذي يتم
تمثل في اعلان مصدر امني قبل دقائق قليله
من الان ان عدد ضحايا اعتداء باريس قادر
ارتفع الى ثلاثه قتله عدد الجرح ثلاثه
ايضا احدهم في حال الخطر واثنان اخران
مصابان بجراح متوسطه كنت ذكرت خلال
المداخله معك خالد بعد دقائق من وقوع
الاعتداء ان الرجل اطلق النار المعتدي
اطلق النار قرب مركز كردي ولكن لم نكن
نعرف طبيعه هذا المركز ومدى العلاقه بينما
فعله المعتدي وهذا المركز الكردي تبين لنا
الان ان اطلاق النار في جوار المركز
الثقافي الكردي هنا في شارع في الدائره
العاشره في العاصمه الفرنسيه لهذا الحي
لهذه الدائره عموما الدائره العاشره شخصيه
تتمثل في كونها كانت احدى المناطق التي
طاولتها اعتداءات الثالث عشر من نوفمبر من
العام 2015
والتي كانت عباره عن سلسله اعتداءات في
دائرتين العاشره والحاديه عشر في باريس
وفي ملعب استاد فرانس الشهير وايضا مسرح
بتكلو هذه المنطقه كانت واحده من المناطق
التي استهدفت حينها المدعى العامه في
باريس اوضحت وهذا كلام مهم تطابق معك مع
كان ذاكرته مصادر امنيه ان المعتدي نفسه
كان قام باعتداء على مخيم للمهاجرين في
باريس في الثامن من ديسمبر من العام
الماضي اي قبل عام
والثلاثه عشر يوما قبل عام و 15 يوما قام
بالاعتداء على مخيم للاجئين في الدائره
الثانيه 10 في باريس كما اعتدى على
مهاجرين ايضا في ضاحيه برسي القريبه من
العاصمه الفرنسيه وحينها فتحت تحقيق في
الاعتداء الذي قام به وليس معروفا سببه
وجوده حرا طليقا الان هل لانه استفاد من
افراج مشروط عنه ام لانه كان يخضع لمراقبه
قضائيه نجح في الافلات منها كل ذلك قيد
التحقق حاليا من قبل الشرطه وزير الداخليه
الفرنسي جلال دار الموجود الذي كان موجود
في تركيا شمال فرنسا سيعود الى العاصمه
الفرنسيه وسيصل الى هنا الى هذا المكان
بعد قليل للادلاء بتصريحات طبعا ما كان
اعلن ايضا هو انه لم يعثر بحوزه المعتدي
على اوراق ثبوتيه تحدد جنسيته لكن ما ذكر
ايضا انه قام باكثر من اعتداء له طبيعه
عنصريه اذا ثبتت هذه المعلومات واصبحت
رسميه ونهائيه فان للامر دلالات مختلفه
والتحقيق يتخذ مجرا اخر هذه المره خالد
يعني هل من المعتاد تكرار مثل هذه الحوادث
ان يكون شخص متهم وله ثوابق همم ان يكون
حرا طليقا ربما يقوم بمثل هذه الاعمال في
فرنسا حسين
لوزاره الداخليه
والشرطه بعض الذين قاموا باعتداءات في
شوارع باريس ومدن فرنسيه اخرى كانت لهم
ثوابق وهذا كان موضع انتقاد من جهات عده
من احزاب وايضا من مواطنين استغربوا ان
يكون اشخاص قاموا بما قاموا به تمكنوا من
الافلات من العقاب وتمكنوا من تعريض حياه
الناس للخطر مجددا اذكر ايضا خالد في
المعلومات الوارده الينا ان المعتدي الذي
قام باعتدائه حواله ثانيه 10 ظهرا
بالتوقيت المحلي اخرج من كيس كان يحمله
مسدسا اسودا وراح يطلق النار من هذا
المسدس قبل ان يتمكن عدد من الاشخاص من
السيطره عليه وبعد ذلك الشرطه عليه وكان
مصابا في وجهه جراحه متوسطه حياته ليست في
خطر كما تقول المعلومات الوارده حتى الان
خالد شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس مراسل
العربيه حسين فياض قنيبل
ايضا نبقى في باريس انضم الينا الان
المحلل السياسي ناصر الزهير اهلا وسهلا بك
معي سيد ناصر
عنصريه خلف هذا الاعتداء كما جاء ايضا من
قبل مكتب الادعاء الفرنسي بعد هذه الحادث
كيف يمكن النظر الى الدلالات والتداعيات
المتوقع
يعني سيكون لدينا كثير من التبعات لهذه
الحادثه عندما تنتضح الامور بشكل نهائي هل
هو حادث عنصري يستهدف المهاجرين او مراكز
المهاجرين خاصه ان المتهم في كلا الحالتين
تطابقت ال الدوافع الجريمه فيما يتعلق
فيها السابق في العام الماضي كما ذكر
مراسليكم بان هناك اعتداء على مخيم
للمهاجرين وايضا في هذا العام عندما اعتدى
على مركز لاستقبال المهاجرين الاكراد
ولذلك في كلا الحالتين سيكون هناك اعتقد
تابعه تتعلق اولا في انه واقع العنصريه
نقطه الثانيه فيما يتعلق في اشكاليه هنا
في فرنسا وهي التي تحدثت عنها ان يكون
هناك اشخاص او حاولوا القيام بجرائم وكان
عنصريه
ولا زالوا طليقين او لا زال بامكانهم
الحصول على اسلحه والقيام بمثل هذه
العمليات او بين قوسين هم ليسوا تحت
المراقبه الشديده اذا كان وضعهم في السجن
هو امر صعب للغايه ولذلك اعت بانه سيكون
هناك تعديلات معينه او مطالبات بتعديلات
معينه في هذه المسارات وفي هذه القطط في
طريقه تصرف الشرطه الفرنسيه ومكافحه
الارهاب هذا قد يؤخذ من ناحيه امنيه يعني
خاصه بعد الملاحظات والانتقادات الكثيره
لوجهه وزاره وجهه لوزاره الداخليه حديثه
وجود شخص له ثواب قربما تكررت كما قال
مراسلنا لكن على مستوى يعني المجتمع
الفرنسي
وايضا الاتهامات بالعنصريه وكذلك مساله
قبول اللاجئين هل يمكن النظر الى ربما
تاثيراته متبعات لهذا الامر ولهذه الحادثه
مستقبله
دائما في فرنسا هي مساله العنصريه او
استهداف المهاجرين او عدم قبولهم ولكن دان
يقول بان فرنسا هي تعتبر مقارنه في دول
اوروبيه اخرى هي من اقل او اقل من الدول
التي فيها مثل هذه الحوادث لانها دائما
تعتبر حوادث فرديه حوادث
مستوى المجتمع او نظره المجتمع الفرنسي لي
تقبل المهاجرين وهذا منعكس على سبيل
المثال في الفتره الاخيره في مساله فريق
كاس العالم الذي ينحدر معظم الفرنسيين فيه
من اصول مهاجره واخرج الطبقه السياسيه
تقول بانها مساله ادماج وقبول المهاجرين
اتت بنتائج بان هذا الفريق قتل كاس العالم
لفرنسا وفي مرحله لاحقه كاد ان يحصل على
النسخه الثانيه ايضا هي في مساله تصاعد
نظره اليمين المتطرف الذي يحاول الان ان
يغير من جلده وان يسعى الى تغيير اليه
خطابه المعاديه للمهاجرين والعنصريه نوعا
ما الذي كان يلتهم فيها ولذلك الان اعتقد
بان هذه الحادثه قد يكون لديها اثر سلبي
نوعا ما ولكن هي ايضا تدفع لمواجهه هذه
النظره وهذه التصرفات او تدفع حتى القوه
الامنيه لي متابعه هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين
يشكلون خطر على الامن الفرنسي ولكن
المجتمع الفرنسي في عمومه لديه دائما هذه
الجداليه الموجوده في متعلق فيه الاسلام
او التطرف او حتى قبول المهاجرين وحتى في
ذلك يقول بين الفرنسيين انفسهم ولكن مسيطر
عليها الى حد هذه اللحظه ولا لم تنفلت
الامور كما حدث في ايطاليا على سبيل
النساء منذ سنوات عندما تولى سلبيني
السلطه واصلحت نبره الخطاب المعادي
للمهاجرين عاليه جدا ايضا كما حدث في
المانيا مثلا مع حزب البديل ولذلك دائما
يكون لدينا المدن من هذه النبره ثم تتراجع
بشكل او باخر شكرا جزيلا لكم باريس المحلل
السياسي ناصر زهير
رفضت القوات المواليه لروسيا الانسحاب من
محطه
كبيره في نزل اوكرانيا ونشره وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه فيديو للمناورات البريه بين
القوات الروسيه والبيلاروسيا مثيره لان
الغرض من هذه التدريبات والتنسيق القتاليه
واظهرت اللقطات التي نشرتها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه مجموعه من الجنود وهم يجرون
تدريباتهم على الدبابات والصواريخ
هذا هو فائده صحيفه واشنطن بوست بان
التوافق بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ونظيره الاوكراني فلاد ميرسي لم يكن في
اوجه خلال زياره الاخير لواشنطن وان
اختلافات كثيره برزت بين الجانبين من
ضمنها ضمان ودعم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
الجديده في مجلس النواب لتمرير حزمه ب 47
مليار دولار من المساعدات الاوكرانيا نقلت
صحيفه عن مصادر في البيت الابيض قولها ان
بعيد كان يرغب في مناقشه موقف زالنسكي
بشان الدبلوماسيه ومعرفه تقيمه واحتياجاته
لقبول التفاوض مع روسيا وكشفت ايضا عن
النقاش حول استراتيجيات المقترحه للتسويه
السلميه للازمه حددت فيها ثلاثه
سيناريوهات مختلفه منها خطه السلام التي
اقترحها الشهر الماضي تتضمن سحاب روسيه من
جميع المناطق التي سيطرت عليها تنازل
روسيا عن القرم حتى خطوط 2014
السيناريو الثالث يشمل انسحاب من دون بس
مع احتفاظها بالقرب
وقد بدات سلطات روسيه في هدم مسرح الدراما
التاريخي في مريول بول في محاوله لمحو كل
المظاهر الاوكرانيه من المدينه
[موسيقى]
قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكسندر
نوفاكنه سكر نفطر عالميه متوازنه حاليا من
فضلك
في مقابله تلفزيونيه انا القيامه بذلك ليس
من اجل مصلحه المنتجين فحسب بل كذلك
لمصلحه المستهلكين لضمان وضع مستقر في
السوق واشار المسؤول الروسي
تحقيق التوازن بالسوق اثناء انخفاض الطلب
على النفط في فصل الشتاء وتراجعه بسبب
تداعيات فيروس كورونا لا سيما في الصين
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
تشكيليه لجان لحصر الاضرار التي لحقت
بالممتلكات نتيجه الامطار التي شهدت مكه
اليوم
اهلا بكم من جديد رفع مركز الارصاد الوطني
للارصاد في السعوديه حاله التنبيه على
مناطق من غرب البلاد الى تنبيه المتقدم
تقرير الارصاد كشف كذلك عن توقعات تشير
الى هطول امطار الراديو من متوسطه الى
غزيره
في ذات التقرير عن توقعات الاخرى حول
انخفاض درجات الحراره على مناطق منها مكه
والمدينه المنوره والحدود الشماليه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
اولا عبد الواحد الحميد عبد الواحد مرحبا
بك كيف تبدو الصوره في مكه المكرمه الان
مع استمرار هطول الامطار ربما عليه
او بعد توقفها كمان مشاهده
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى حيث كانت الامطار
بشكل متفرق وموزع على انحاء العاصمه
المقدسه صاحبها كذلك يعني سحب رعديه كما
ذكرت في انحاء متباعده في العاصمه المقدسه
هذه الامطار كانت مستمره
بشكل جزئيه على المناطق متنوعه ومختلفه
كانت قد تسببت ببعض الاضرار الجزئيه في
بعض الاحياء همم الشعبيه لكنها بشكل عام
تقريبا قبل ساعه او ساعه ونصف من الان
انتهت او انتهى ال- همم التنبيه الذي
اصدره المركز الوطني للارصاد فيما يتعلق
ب- يعني في الجانب الاخر من همم هذه
الامطار كانت هناك استعدادات كبيره من قبل
امانه العاصمه المقدسه بالتزامن مع هذا
التحذير الذي اصدره المركز الوطني للارصاد
حيث ان فرق الامانه كانت همم بشكل مستمر
تجوب الاحياء يعني وتقوم بسحب التجمعات
مياه الامطار اضافه الى ازاله اثار همم
الاشجار
يعني المتساقطه وكذلك نتحدث ان بعض
الاحياء كما تعلم خالد تحيط بها همم
الجبال بالتالي كان هناك همم يعني ربما
رمال من جرفه او بعض الحجاره كانت امانه
العاصمه مقدسه تقوم بشكل مستمر بازاله همم
كل هذه الاثار همم خالد اضافه الى كل هذا
يعني مكه المكرمه تضم شبكه ضخمه لتصريف
مياه الامطار همم تحت الارض تتجاوز او
يتجاوز طولها اكثر من 540 كم بالتالي همم
المنطقه والمدينه يعني محصنا بالكامل همم
كنا نتحدث عن التصريف مياه الامطار همم
يعني في مختلف انحاء همم مكه المكرمه في
هذا المكان الذي اطلق فيه تحديدا كانت
هناك امطار في صباح اليوم يعني ولكن كما
تشاهد لا يوجد اثار كبيره الامطار بالعكس
يعني اغلب مياه جفت وبالتالي يعني في بعض
الاحياء ربما تضررت يعني نحن ننقب في ممشا
النسيم في مكه المكرمه تمتداول بعض الصور
والفيديوهات لبعض الاحياء التي تضررت ربما
يعني
سيول او امطار غزيره كثير من السيارات
شهدناها وعدد من السيارات المتكدس همم في
بعض الاحياء اي تركزات اذا كان لديك
معلومات عن حجم هذه الاضرار
الذي اصابه هذه الاخيره
نعم خالد فيما يتعلق انا شاهدت صور
متداوله حقيقه وكانت هذه الصور تحديدا من
مناطق محدده نتحدث عن حي العتيبيه وادي
جليل شارع الحج هذه المناطق هي التي تضررت
هذه المناطق يعني في الحقيقه ليست مخططه
بشكل جيد وبالتالي يعني كان هناك بعض
السيارات المتضرره شاهدنا بعض همم السيول
الرمال المنجرفه بكل تاكيد لكن نتحدث عن
بقيه مناطق همم واحياء مكه المكرمه يعني
قبل المباشر نحن قمنا بجوله في مختلف
احياء مكه المكرمه غالبيه الاحياء خالد لم
تتضرر انما احياء بسيطه يعني مناطق محدوده
هي التي تضررت سواء كان ذلك همم جرف
الرمال والحجاره او حتى تضرر بعض السيارات
من خلال السيول
طيب شكرا لك من مكه المكرمه مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد الحميد
اعلنت المديريه العامه للدفاع المدني في
السعوديه انها بدات بتشكيل لجان لحصر
الاضرار التي لحقت بالممتلكات نتيجه
الامطار التي شاهدتها او شهدتها مدينه مكه
اليوم الجمعه مشيره الى انه سيتم الوقوف
على مواقع الادرار من قبل لجان متخصصه
تشهد السعوديه النقله في الخدمات المقدمه
للاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه في العديد من
المجالات داخل القطاعين الحكومي والخاص
بهدف تحسين نمط حياتهم وتقديم المزيد من
المبادرات والتسهيلات التي تضمن زياده
الخدمات ودعم حقوق ذوي الاعاقه المزيد مع
مراسلنا على الله
[موسيقى]
حزمه من الخدمات والتسهيلات احضى بها
الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه في السعوديه تقدمها
القطاعات الحكوميه والخاصه بهدفي تحسين
نوعيه حياتهم ابرز وتلك الخدمات بطاقه
تسهيلات والتي تمكن الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه
من الحصول على العديد من المزايا في
الخدمات المقدمه لهم تم اصدار بطاقات
تسهيلات للاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه بالتعاون مع
الهيئه السعوديه البيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي هدايا
باصدار هذه البطاقه من خلال تطبيق خدمات
توكلنا خدمات وهو يمكن جميع الاشخاص لو
الاعاقه واولياء امورهم من الحصول على هذا
البطاقه والاطلاع عليها واستخدامها همم من
خلال هذا التطبيق تمنح البطاقه مزايا
للمستفيدين في تخفيض اجور السفر والنقل
عبر وسائل النقل الحكوميه بنحوه 50% وتوفر
اولويه الحصول على الخدمات اضافه سير
الدخول في القطاعات الحكوميه والمرافق
الخاصه وامكانيه الاستفاده من مواقف
المرافق العامه دون قيود البطاقه ساعدتنا
كثير في انك تكون عندنا مسار خاص للاشخاص
او الاعاقه ايضا ساعدتنا في ايجاد خصم 50%
لحاملي هذه البطاقه من الاشخاص او الاعاقه
ايضا ساهمت معنا فليكون هناك موظفي
يخدمونك على مدار الساعه مشكورين على انه
ما تتاخر وتعرف انه ضرر التاخير للاشخاص
شديده الاعاقه من الجلوس والانتظار الطويل
تستاهل عليك اموره تذاكر الطيران يعني
تخفيض الطيران واو على كم شقه لما اخذوا
الملعب تغب علينا لما احضر قبل المباراه
ساعتين لكن الحين ممكن قبل المباراه ساعه
احضر
وكذلك لما اروح الدوائر الحكوميه سواء
مواقف السيارات او همم داخل همم الدائره
الحكوميه
حتى مقتل اني امسك سيره او اخذ رقم تتولى
العديد من المبادرات المجتمعيه والحكوميه
التي تصب اهتمامها في رفعه مستوى كفاءه
الخدمات المقدمه لذوي الاعاقه وادراك
احتياجاتهم على النحو الذي يسهم في تقديم
افضل تسهيلات وتعزيز حقوقهم داخل المجتمع
[موسيقى]
من المنطقه الشرقيه علي اللقب العربيه
قناه العربيه اهلا وسهلا انت حصلت على
البطاقه ولم بطاقه تسهيل اي حصل عليها
لانها الكترونيه يعطيك الموقع وش فائده وش
الفرق اللي حسيته بينها وبين البطاقه اللي
كانت موجوده او سابق هي في الحقيقه هي فقط
تقدم نفس الخدمه السابقه اللي كانت تقدمها
البطاقه التقليديه همم لكن اصبح اصدارها
اسهل
وقد تقلل في المستقبل ان شاء الله من قضيه
استغلال همم يعني مواقف ذوي الاعاقه
تسهيلات الخاصه فيهم همم اذا تم تفعلها
بشكل كويس من قبل همم الجهات الامنيه
والمسؤولين عن مواقف ذوي الاعاقه بحيث انه
ما يكتشفون فقط بالبطاقه التقليديه اللي
بتصور في المكتبات هذه صور لها الواحد 10
النسخه للاسره كلها همم يصير البطاقه هذه
هي اللي يعتمد فيها فقط في في الحصول على
المواقف او الخدمات المختلفه فهي جيده لحد
كبير لكن نتمنى تفعيلها بشكل افضل واكبر
يعني افهم منها لسه ما فعله بشكل كامل همم
الى الان في بعض الجهات انا من الناس اللي
استخدمتها يعني ممكن همم بنسبه 5:10 من
الجهات اللي طلبت مني البطاقه الالكترونيه
اللي فيها باركود لتصديرها لان الوزاره
حاليا الباقي لا مجرد ما تعطيها او تحط
بطاقه الاعاقه على طبلون السياره او ان
تكون موجوده في جنب لوحه السياره يدخلك في
موقف المعاقين وهذا في اجحاف كبير حقيقه
اللي ذوي الاعاقه وخصوصا اللي مثلي مثلا
من انا وزملائي اللي يقودون السياره اللي
عنده سواق ممكن ينزل المعاق اللي معاشه
كبير سن او شيء
ويجد موقف عادي هو لكن انا بالنسبه لي همم
صرت ما اجد موقف كل من على قولتهم صار
عنده كل منها
في بعضهم اصلا لو يشعر باي شيء يصور
البطاقه
المداخل همم الوزارات والاماكن المعينه بس
صار يستغلها في همم كثير من الاوقات يعني
الميزه فيها بطاقه سهله
همم تقدم 50% تخفيض لذوي الاعاقه في وسائل
النقل المختلفه تعرف احنا ما عندنا وسائل
النقل لا طيران حاليا ومع الاسف هذه يعني
ملاحظه ودي همم يعني همم نوه عنها انه
مثلا تروح للطيران الان يقول لك انت ما
تطلع انت كمعاقب مرافق تروح لوزاره
الموارد البشريه يقول لك لا انت مثلا
النصفي ما تحتاج مرافق طيب الربع يحلونه
انت تطلب مني بطاقه طيب هذه بطاقه البطاقه
مكشوف فيها لا يحتاج مرافق تطلع روح عنده
طيران يقول لك لا يحتاج مرافق تمام مع انه
البطاقه مكتوب عليها
يعني
خطوط الطيران خصوصا المحليه اللي عندنا
هنا ما يطلع المعاق اصلا ما يقبل الحجر
مجرد ما تعطيه انه انا معاق ما يقبلك
كمعاقه فهمت عليه بعض طيران ما تقبل منه
ممكن ان شاء الله
هذه بس الميزه الوحيده
اا انه الخدمات المقدمات اقتصر على تخفيض
اجور السفر صحيح لكن اللي عليها علامات
استفهام كبيره
عن طريق الانظمه بنظام ابشر مثلا تستفيد
منها في الجوازات الجوازات الان يمنح مثلا
همم تاشيرات لذوي الاعاقه سواء تاشيره
خادمه او سائق همم او همم ممرض اذا احتاج
حسب التقرير الطبي حق فنحتاج انها تكون
مربوطه فيها ايضا المرور لما يكون هذا
البطاقه مربوطه بلوحه سياره المعاق
بالايدي نمبر حقه برقم الهويه الوطنيه هنا
ممكن ما تخالفه اذا ما وجد موقفه وقف في
موقف مثلا قد بعض احيان يكون يضر
المخالفه او كذا قضيه اخرى انه يصير فيه
تسهيلات خاصه للمرور
ايضا وزاره الصحه بقيه الوزارات الاخرى
المختلفه نتمنى ان انتم تكون مربوطه زي في
النهفات الوطني الان يصير عندك مثلا انه
والله انا اعرف الاستاذ خالد ولا يحيى
من دوله وبالتالي يقدم له تسهيلات اللي
همم يفترض ان تكون له موجوده في همم الجهه
لكنها فقط اذا كان يعني همم اقتصر دورها
على مواقف السيارات حقيقه راح يكون دور
مثلا في دول ديما مثلا تحصل حتى يونيك
نمبر او اكسس للمعاق ممكن نستخدم البطاقه
دي في اي مكان انا مجرد ما امررها زي
الباركود مثلا في المويه كيف ما احتاج حتى
تشكلتي يفتح لي البوابه او شيء من القبيله
اطول انا ممكن ادخل استفيد من الخدمات
الموجوده بشكل تلقائيا يمكن في هذه الدول
اللي ذكرتها هناك في جهات تقوم بالدور
بالتقديم ال همم المميزات الخدمات
التسهيلات كذلك بالنسبه للحقوق هنا يمكن
اسال عن الهيئه هيئه رعايه الاشخاص دوله
اللي ممكن تقدم خدمات في هذا المجال هل هي
في 1439 قبل خمس سنوات تقريبا
اطلقته
وانا دخلت على موقعهم انا ما لقيت شيء
يعني انت كيف شايف كواحد من هذه الفئه
الدور هذه الهيئه بعد خمس سنوات على فكره
هو في الموقع ما في المذكره تفاهم تم
التوقيعها مع رابطه الدوري الدرجه الاولى
الدوري
الاهلاويه يمكن ههه وفي اتفاقيه تعاون مع
هيئه التدريب والتعليم انت شايف اي جهود
بدل من قبل هذه خمس سنوات مش خمس سنوات
فيها يقولوا قبل ثلاثه شهور توه يتم تعيين
احد المسؤولين فيهم لوضع استراتيجيه
للهيئه بعد خمس سنوات
المعاقين مع الاسف مع وجود الهيئه انه الى
الان يعني وقد يكون مخطئ في هذا التصور او
الفعل الهيئه لم تفهم دورها الاساسي الذي
انشئت من اجل يعني الشاب خالد الان همم
اتفاقيه مع
المحلات توقع اتفاقيه مع
جهات معينه ما تفيد المعقيله من قريب ولا
من بعيد همم كان لهم مبادره يعني يتتاخرون
بها كثيرا وهي اطلاق السبت البنفسجي
هذا يقدم تخفيضات في في المغاسل في
المطاعم اا يوم واحد في السنه تمام ويقول
لك والله لا واليوم الواحد هو تلحق ما
تلحق يعني في بعض الاماكن تقدم خدمات او
تخفيضات لمده يومين ثلاثه ايام لكن الهيئه
مع الاسف ثم بدات الهيئه تبادر
توقيعتفاقيات مع البنوك توقعات هذا هذا
ليس دور الهيئه الهيئه فيما نفهم نحن همم
دورها تشريعي رقابي لكل الوزارات والجهات
المعنيه بخدمه الدول الاعاقه وبالتالي
دوره اشمل واكبر واهم من قضيه انك تتوقع
اتفاقيات او تتمنى بعض الاحيان مبادرات
لذوي الاعاقه تبن مبادره همم جاهز قهوه
الاخ محمد الشريف مبادره عمار همم
للموهوبين وكانهم همم اصبحوا
لا انا ولا زملائي الى الان الكل يتساءل
ما شفنا الى الان بعد خمس سنوات اي همم
عمل يذكر همم او يشفع للهيئه وجودها في
هذا المكان اشكرك شكرا جزيلا حياه
الزهراني يناشط في حقوق المراه شكرا لكم
في ضربه السعوديه اطلقت محافظه الخيبر عده
تجارب للسياح والزيار من افتتاح
الرام التاريخي بالاضافه الى التدشين
الرحلات عبر المناطيد والطائرات المروحيه
التي يتاح من خلالها لركاب مشاهده الحصون
وعيون المياه في خيبر مع النظر عن قرب
للمصائد والتي يعود الى العصر الحجري
من مثل الواحه الروان في خيبر ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف مرحبا بك
يعني مشاهداتك في هذه الواحه كيف رصدته
نعم خالد تم تحويل المطل واحه الروان الى
مزار سياحي يمكن جميع السياح والزوار في
المملكه من القدوم والتعرف اكثر على تراث
خيبر وتاريخها الممتد للالاف السنين هنا
يستقبل هذا المطل العديد من السياح بدءا
من مركز الاستقبال كما نشاهد هنا الذي
يستقبل السياح بوجود عروض وايضا رواه
يقدمون كامل المعلومات التاريخيه للزوار
عن همم خيبر والتاريخها الممتد لالاف
السنين هنا ايضا متاجر في هذا المطال
المتعدده تعرض العديد من المنسوجات
والمعروضات المرتبطه بخيبر اضافه الى ان
الرحلات الى هذا المطل
مسهله بشكل كبير الزوار من العلا الذين
يزورون شتاء طنطوره والمواقع التاريخ هي
هناك همم يتم نقلهم عبر ال النقل الترددي
عبر الحافلات وايضا هناك عده محطات همم
للاستراحه لدى السياح الذين ياتون من
العلا ومن المناطق الاخرى على سبيل المثال
العلا هناك خيمه تسمى الخيمه البدويه او
المخيم البدوي بعد العلا ب 120 كيلو يتوقف
السياح او تتوقف في الحافلات هناك همم
للتعرف على الثقافه السعوديه
كما نشاهد هذه هي واحد
الروان التي تحيط بها العديد من المظلات
وهذا واحد من المطلات وكمان نشاهد على
اليسار خالد هناك العديد من الجلسات
المفتوحه التي تنقل الزوار والسياح الى
اجواء اخرى وايضا يوجد مطعم همم مبني داخل
احدى البيوت القديمه او شيء داخل احدى
البيوت القديمه تحرص هنا الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلا وهي التي تتولى اداره مثل
هذه المواقع على عدم همم التغيير في بناء
همم المباني عند انشاء اي مطاعم او مشاريع
تتم في هذه الاماكن للحفاظ على البناء
التراثي لها وعدم التاثر فيه وكما نعلم ان
الجهات هنا خاصه الجهات الحكوميه التي
لديها العديد من المناطق التاريخيه تحرص
على الحفاظ على المواقع التاريخيه كونها
مرتبطه بمنظمات العالميه التي تتواصل
وتضيف بعض المواقع التاريخيه مثل اليونسكو
وغيرها من المنظمات هذا المكان حقيقه ياتي
ضمن مهرجان الممالك القديمه الذي يربط
ثلاث ممالك او ثلاث واحات قديمه مثل هذه
الواحه وايضا في تيماء والع وكما نعلم ان
الشتاء طنطوره يساهم بشكل كبير في جذب
الزوار الذين يرغبون بالتعرف اكثر على
المواقع التاريخيه في السعوديه من خلال
زياره مثل هذه الاماكن شهدنا منذ بدايه
هذا اليوم زياره العديد من السياح وايضا
كما ذكرت في الخبر خالد ان هناك همم تدشين
للعديد من التجارب الجديده مثل همم
الطائرات وايضا المناطيد لمشاهده خيبر من
الاعلى وعن قرب لبعض الاماكن التي لا يمكن
مشاهدتها في الارض على همم هذه الاماكن
شكرا لك من واحد في خير
رابع ايضا بعد الفاصل
رياض محافظه رفح تستقبل زوارها ومحبي
الطبيعه باللون الاخضر
شركه بالقطاع الخاص
لثبوت لتوظيف اكثر من 40 مواطن بشكل سوري
بهدف التحايل على نسب التوطين للحصول على
المزايا والدعم المادي من البرامج المخصصه
للمواطنين المعينين بالقطاع الخاص
والاستفاده من مزايا برامج
استكملت شركه السعوديه لاستثمار الزراعي
والانتاج الحيواني سالب المملوكه لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه
35 و 43 من المئه في المئه من شركه اولام
الزراعيه القابضه بقيمه تبلغ اربعه
مليارات وخمسه
و650 مليون ريال واكدت السيلكان الصفقات
تعد خطوه للوصول الى الرياده في مجال
الامن الغذائي لان الشركتين ستعملان على
التعاون المشتركه للمساهمه في تربيه
الطالب العالمي على الغذاء وتعد شركه ولاء
من الشركات العالميه الرائده في مجال
الحبوب والارز والاعلاف وزيوت الطعام
السعوديه يوصلوا مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز
للابل في نسخته السابعه استقبال الزوار مع
اقامه فعالياته المقامه تحت شعار همه
تطويق النسخه السابعه من مهرجان الابل
شهادات اجراءات تطبق للمره الاولى من
التعديل عدد المتون المشاركه في فئات سيف
الملك
استديوهات هنا ينضم الينا متحدث مهرجان
لابن محمد الحربي استاذ محمد حياك الله
اهلين اهلين حياك الله المشاهدين ابدا اول
شيء من موضوع الجديد في مهرجان هذا العام
او المختلف عن المهرجان العام الماضي
بالتاكيد احنا اليوم نتكلم عن ست نسخ ماضي
هذه النسخه السابعه دائما يوجد في الجديد
سواء في المنافسات او المشاركات او حتى في
انواع الفعاليات المقامه هناك همم الشوط
البداوه هذا العام الجديد من الاشواط
الجديده ايضا دخول الشوط النسائي يضمنا
الاشواط الملكيه باسم شوط الاميره نوره
بنت عبد الرحمن تخليدا لهذه المراه
العظيمه هذه من الاشياء الجديده والعديد
من الفعاليات المصاحبه سواء على مستوى
الملاك او سواء على العمل التجاري الموجود
في المهرجان هو الموضوع اللي دائما اثار
كل مهرجان
وهنا سؤال ليش المملكه تهتم
بمزاين الابل بمسابقات جمال
بالتاكيد نحن اليوم نتكلم عن ارث تاريخي
عن ارتباط وثيق بين الانسان والابل واعاده
الامم انت تهتم بتراثها وتحقيق يعني او
التعريف به للاخرين هذا الاهتمام متواصل
ايضا منذ بدايه الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والثانيه والثالثه الملك عبد العزيز رحمه
الله اعتمد على الاعتماد رئيسي في توحيد
اجزاء هذه البلاد وبالتالي هذا الاهتمام
غير مستغرب على على ان نهتم بشكل سوء بشكل
حكومي او بشكل همم يعني من المواطنين في
هذه المسابقات الاقتصادي على البلد يعني
من خلال هذا المعركه يعني اقول لك يعني من
خلال المهرجان همم دائما ملاك الابل
يبحثون عن الانتاج الجيد وبالتالي هناك
مواطن موجود في صحراء الربع الخالي ومواطن
اخر موجود في اقصى شمال المملكه وبال
للشراء وعمليه البيع تعود على هؤلاء
بالنفع دائما ملاك الابل يبحثون عن
الانتاج الجيد وبالتالي يبحثون في اي مكان
همم عاده تعزيز المنجيات همم يجعل لي يجعل
للاستفاده كبيره جدا اضافه الى الاسواق
المتناثره لاسواق الابل الموجوده في
السعوديه فيها حراك اقتصادي كبير فيها بيع
وشراء بين الملاك انفسهم او بين المربين
والملاك دائما البحث عن السلالات والجمال
هاجسي يومي ربما ليس لمجرد المهرجان وانما
على مدار السنه
هنشوف ارقام يعني مليونيه كبيره يعني في
اسعار الابل
يعني ملايين قد يصل عشره ملايين ربما ليش
ترتفع اسعار الابل بهذه الطريقه بهذه
الارقام يمكن كبيره فلكيه تعتبر
سلعه في النهايه سلعه مطلوبه سلعه مندو
بدايه معرفه الانسان في الابل يستفيد منها
في السفر والترحال كانت وسيله نقل اهم
وسيله نقل على وجه الارض همم واسعارها منذ
الازل لم تكن رخيصه الابل هذا ما هو شيء
جديد في في ارتفاع سعرها اليوم احنا نتكلم
على قبل المزاين
ليست كثيره ربما الطلب اكثر من العرض لا
يوجد معروض ولذلك يتنافس الملاك عاده على
الابل لدى المربيين مثلا او لدى المنتجين
همم باسعار عاليه ترتفع هي مثلها مثل اي
السلع همم سلعه اخرى يجوز عليها البيع
والشراء والتاجير وكذلك الرهن همم
وبالتالي هذه منطقي ايضا خليني اضربها من
جهه اخرى يعني في سلع اخرى همم ربما يعني
عند شراء باسعار عاليه تنقص لمنها لابن لا
ينقص ثمنها الابل تسجيل لانك تتعامل مع
كائن حي كائن حي ينتج كائن حي اخر
وبالتالي هي منظور اقتصاده
تاريخ الابل لم تكن رخيصه الابل كانت تقدر
الهدايا الملوك من الابل هدايا هدايا ايضا
اغلى ما يهدى الى مكه المكرمه للحجاج من
الابل في في التاريخ يعني قصص كثيره جدا
حول قيمتها واهميتها بل كانت هي المال
سجل حذاء الابل ضمن التراث العالمي
اليونسكو او الهبال
تاثير هذا التسجيل سواء كان على المهرجان
القائمين على ايضا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
يعني هذه ضمن الاهازيج المرتبطه بين
المالك والابل قصه حذاء الابل يعني قصه
ليست جديده بل هي تعود الى همم جد العرب
قصه مشهوره انه عندما سقط من ابنه كان
صوته جميل فاخذ يصرخ ويداه ويداه ويجتمعت
حول الابل وبالتالي منها من هذه القصه
انطلق 11 الابل والتصويت لها اليوم هذه
العلاقه بين المالك الابل وابنه هذا الصوت
الجميل همم اللي يطلقه اللي تعرفه الابل
وتصير نحو همم يعني هذا نعرف العالم فيه
واحده من اهم استجابات
بين الانسان وبين كائن حي التسجيل هذا
الملف اليونس كل واحد من من الذي يعرف
بتراثنا بتاريخنا السعودي بتراثنا العريق
هذا الملف قامت هيئه التراث بالتسجيله
بالتعاون مع نادي الابل اليوم احنا نحتفل
بهذا التسجيل وكاد يمارس بشكل يومي من
خلال مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز همم اهداء
الابل اول هوبال او العوبال سمم ما شئت من
المسميات الحقيقيه
ومختلف يمكن هذه السنه السابقات في تطور
في تقدم في الموضوع لكن كشخص مثلي يعني
غير مهتم بهذا الموضوع
هذا المهرجان يعني
طبعا همم الدافع هو انت تعرف هذا التراث
تعرف همم تراثنا العريق واحده من اهم يعني
الفعاليات الموجوده هي عروض الابل لما
يذكر مثلا انه والله في ناقه زينه او ناقه
مزيونه على قولتهم همم هذا هذا اثار
استغراب البعض وبالتالي هو اتعب مواطن
الجمال يجد استفسارات او تجاب على اغلب
استفساراتهم خلال الحضور ومشاهده العروض
وفعلا يعني كثير من الناس حتى الاجانب لما
يزورون هنا يقولون فعلا هذه اناقه جميله
همم عندما يشاهدونه لانها في مواصفات
مختلفه تماما همم ربما يعني ما يعرفها همم
يعني العادي في الشارع العادي لكن عندما
يحضر في الموقع ويشاهد فعلا العروض حتى
مشيت الناقه لها صفه جماليه الرقبه لها
صفه جماليه الراس لها صفه جميله هذه
الاسئله احيانا كثير الفضول لدى البعض
لمعرفه المزيد فعلا يعني لما يزورون
الموقع سواء في شارع الدهنه بمنتجاته
المرتبطه في الابل او الفعاليات المحيطه
او خيمه الباديه والفعاليات الموجوده فيها
صوت الربابه همم الابل اللي تسير بشكل
كامل الفعاليات المقاومه صالونات الادبيه
لمقاومه نعم لانه عاده يسبق مشاركه الملاك
في مخيماتهم تسبق الليله اللي تسبق
مشاركته يقي احتفال ااا احتفال شعري
اهازيج همم غناء كل انواع يعني يعني همم
الطرب يحدث في هذه المخيمات هذه نعتبرها
من الفعاليات اللي يحرص كثير من الزوار
ولذلك بعض الحفلات يحضرها بالالاف بل
تضييق المكان احيانا همم وخلال الاسابيع
القادمه نتوقع ان يشهد يعني المنافسه
احتدام كبير لانه الاشواط الجمل هتكون
قادمه باذن الله الايام القادمه وبالتالي
هتكون المخيمات محتدمه المنافسه محتدمه
المخيمات متهيئه ومجهزه لهذه الروح يا
محمد الله ههه
شكرا شكرا
اكتست البياض في صحراء محافظه رفحاء في
منطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه والمراكز
التابعه باللون الاخضر شجع ذلك محبي البر
والمتنزهين للخروج والاستمتاع بالاجواء
الربيعين جزاء النماصي وثق مناظر الربيع
في بعض من هذه البيضه
[موسيقى]
طبعا مهرجان السعوديه
المختلف مناطق السعوديه ليصنع جو من
التنافس على جذب الحضور والفوز بالجوائز
لافضل الاطباق اليوميه بهدفي نشر ثقافه
الاكل السعودي وتطويره
كتمت ام محمد من اقصى شمال السعوديه
حامله على عتيقها نشر اكلات تميزت بها
مدينه والجوف
نجحت بجد الامطار في مهرجان للاكلات
السعوديه الذي يهتف لاعاده تسويق ونشر
الاكلات الشعبيه السعوديه
عندنا مقطوطه اللحم كانوا قديما يقولوا
لها المقطوطه وحاليا حنا يتكلمون عنها
خميس اللحم
اختصت به الاحساء
ويتباها روزي مدينته الذي يقول عنه بانه
الاغلى على مستوى العالم حديد
قيمه اعقل شيء يعني تقريبا من 30 الى 35
ما ينزرع الا في المنطقه الشرقيه
بالتحديدا الحسا فقط ما تلقى زي هذا الرز
الحساوي فوائده كثيره وجمع تحاول هيئه
فنون الطهي عبر هذا المهرجان من تقديم
الاكل السعودي بطرق حديثه لينافس الاكلات
الرائجه ويعود بالنفع الاقتصاديه على
صناعه المحليين
يضل الاكل الشعبي هو الاصل يعني خاصه وقت
الشتاء دخول الشتاء الان مرقوق المطازيز
الاجيال
رز عندهم وعندهم جريش
اكثر من البرجر
خليك صادق
المهرجانات هذه يمكن لان اكثر الشباب
الصغار ما يعرفون شيء الاكلات شعبيه يمكن
اكثر شيء يبين الاكلات الشعبيه المهرجانات
هذه يمكن تعيده الى افضل من
الهمبرجر والمشويات والحاجات اللي يعني
راح للحين اكثر الشباب واكثر الناس
ياكلون فيها لتعزيز في حضور الاكلات
الشعبيه السعوديه يعمل مهرجان للطعام
السعودي على خلقه منافسات لافضل لاطباق
المحليه بجوائز تتخطى 30
عمل تتمحور حول الاكل السعودي
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض
بواسطه بواسطه العاصمه الفرنسيه والنيابه
تعلن انتهاء الحادثه
روسيه تواصل التدريباتها في بيلاروس
الارصاد السعوديه تصدر تحذيرا متقدما من
هطول امطار غزيره على مناطق من غرب البلاد
سالك السعوديه التابعه لصندوق الاستثمارات
تستحوذ على النسبه من شركه سينغو
سنغافوريا بنحو خمسه مليار
ومهرجان في استهلاك السعودي في نسخته
الثانيه يستقدم العشرات من الظهر من مختلف
المناطق
[موسيقى]